Speaker 1: We have yet another former Trump
staffer saying this is serious and Trump may
end up in prison. Here is Mick Mulvaney, Donald
Trump's own former chief of staff previous to
Mark Meadows, saying Trump indeed may end up
doing prison time. I don't even agree with this,
but this is Mick Mulvaney himself saying it.
Speaker 3: If Donald Trump had done what Joe
Biden did here, what Mike Pence did here,
when they found their classified documents,
they gave them back and there's no charges
against Pence. There's not going to be charges
against Biden. The difference here is what Trump
did to try and cover up what he did in the first
place. As is so often the case, it's not the
underlying crime, it's the interference. It's
the cover up that gets folks in trouble. And they
have him with significant evidence, it looks like,
as to obstruction. So I think the chances of a
guilty verdict are fairly high and the chances
of real jailtime are pretty high.
Speaker 2: And what do you say,
real jail time? How long might that be?
Speaker 3: Well, at his age, it doesn't
really make much difference. Right. I think
the maximum, if you add up all the math,
the maximum could be over 500 years.
Speaker 5: The minimum would be 100 year stop.
Speaker 1: I don't even think I agree with Mick
Mulvaney. And I've said all along, I don't believe
Donald Trump will do a day of prison time period.
However, I will say that over the last 72 hours,
I have moved ever so slightly in the direction
of maybe, maybe there will be some jail time
for Trump. It's it's I'm now in the realm of
before I was in absolutely no way in hell.
After speaking to a couple of lawyers, reading
through the indictment, reading about the law
around the allegations for which Trump is going
to be charged. Looking at a few different things
I am now, I've moved from no way in hell Trump
does prison time to. It is extremely unlikely,
but possible, that Trump ends up
with something. It could, however,
end up being one of these. Well, he will serve
it at his house with an ankle monitor, which,
by the way, I would still accept at this
point in time. All right. So Mick Mulvaney
also now on the list of former Trump
staffers who says this is serious and
Trump could be toast. To quote William Barr,
we'll see who else comes out of the woodwork.